It's Earth Day.
And because we've been honoring this beautiful planet
throughout the show,
we need some easy ways that we can all be greener
in our homes year round.
And so we turn to our resident green guru
and dear friend of the show,
editor and chief of "Naturally," Danny Seo, Danny Seo!
(audience cheering)
Hi, happy Earth Day!
Yay!
Take it away. You're in the driver's seat.
What are we doing?
Okay, so tip number one for Earth Day, guys,
if you feel overwhelmed, I always say, do just one thing.
So get rid of those dryer sheets first and foremost.
You don't need them, they're absolutely obsolete.
They're not biodegradable.
They're made outta plastics and things.
So they don't degrade in the landfill and you don't need it.
Okay? This is the alternative.
These are wool dryer balls, guys.
You can buy these, they're reusable almost forever
in your dryer.
What they do is they go
in your dryer and they fluff everything around.
So you're using about 50% less electricity
to dry everything, which means your clothes, your towels,
everything also dries more quickly.
You can add a little essential oil
on the inside to scent everything, which is super nice.
Oh, I've never done that.
And they also get rid of static
because they absorb humidity in the beginning
and then release the excess moisture
throughout the drying cycle to get all the wrinkles out.
They're incredible, you guys,
I'm really.
(audience applauding)
Wait, Drew, do you think some people need these?
Should we?
Do you guys want some, are you guys ready?
Hike your arm.
(Seo laughs)
Happy Earth Day!
What's next, Danny?
Okay, nutshells,
okay?
Nutshells!
So if you have pistachios
or whatever kind of nuts that you love,
save the shells, guys, you can use these
for so many different things.
First and foremost, if the nuts are salted,
you wanna soak them in water for a couple of hours
to get rid of the residual salt.
Because what we're gonna do is, here,
I think we have some gloves if you wanna use 'em
or just use your hands, doesn't matter.
But you're gonna take in your potted plants at home.
You're gonna fill the bottom of your potted plants
with some nutshells and what this does,
it helps with drainage.
And over time, it actually degrades
into a beneficial mulch for your plants.
Really?
So you don't,
'Cause-
You don't put them in the landfill.
I have some potted plants
and I've actually resorted to putting little plates
underneath them because we've all gotten that ring.
Yeah.
And then you
over water and then it just,
(Drew imitates water spilling)
(audience laughing)
What's next, Danny?
Okay,
we're gonna talk about pollinators, guys.
You know, we have to support bees.
We have to support butterflies, but did you know
that when you're planting flowers in your garden
the best choice for pollinators are blue,
periwinkle, these shades in cone flowers,
corn flowers, hydrangeas, they love this
because blue flowers have the highest amount of nectar.
So they're naturally attracted to blue flowers.
So if you can plant as many blue flowers as possible
not only are they gonna love your yard,
they're also gonna make sure your fruit trees, your flowers,
the vegetables you're growing all get pollinated
and you'll have the best yard in the block.
So on our celebration of all things green,
we should plant all things blue.
Blue, exactly.
Okay.
I didn't know that, Danny.
Okay, I like that.
I like that.
Oh my gosh.
That's so amazing.
To go green, let's go blue.
We have teamed up
with an amazing company called Inspire Clean Energy
for this segment.
And Danny, I would love for you to tell us about them.
Oh, I'm obsessed with them
because it's so important to reduce your carbon footprint
with 20% of carbon emissions coming
from home energy use here in the United States.
So one of the biggest steps you can take
to live more sustainably
and create a positive impact on the planet, guys,
is by accessing clean energy for your home,
which means energy from renewable sources
like wind and solar power.
So in Inspire is a clean energy company
that matches the dirty energy your home runs on
with clean, renewable energy
without any interruptions to your service,
no installations either.
It's all digital.
All you can do is sign up online
and with a clean energy plan
like Inspire's your environmental impact for one year,
just one year, can have greater impact
than years of recycling.
Oh my God.
And you just go online
and you're done.
(audience applauding)
I love when technology is good for the planet.
I love when it's easy.
I love this so much.
And if you guys would like to help create a greener future
for our planet today, from the comfort of your home,
please make sure that you check out InspireCleanEnergy.com
and sign up today.
So let's all do it together
as a group effort.
(audience cheering)
Love it.
(cheering continues)
Game time, baby.
(upbeat music)